Okay.
Now we didn't have sections this week in case you didn't notice and therefore
you didn't have an opportunity to discuss the problem set during section.
So I thought I would say a few words about it.
Now here is the problem set.
A,
you probably can't read it at this a typeface,
but that's okay.
Uh,
so let's see.
problems.
Zero is just a stupid way of making you,
uh,
read the,
read the policies.
Nevermind that problem.
Set One problem.
One here our exercises in one digit,
uh,
in one digit scientific notation.
I don't have rules for this.
As I mentioned last time,
the only rule is common sense.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
there might be some difficulty with the last one.
You,
this business of taking,
taking things to the one third power is important because you keep ending up
with a cubed equals something and you have to figure out what to do about that.
So let me not to this particular problem.
Let me do a different one for you.
So supposing you had six times 10 to the four to the one third power,
and you might be tempted to say,
well,
okay,
that's six to the one,
third times 10 to the four thirds,
and that leads you to a bad place because,
uh,
10 to the four thirds is not the notation we want.
We want this to be an integer up there.
Uh,
what does it mean to be a one with four thirds of a zero after it?
and so you don't like that.
So,
uh,
the way to deal with this is to regroup.
This is 60 times 10 to the three to the one third power.
That's 62.
The one third times 10 to the one what?
60 to the one third,
well,
a four times four times four as it happens is 64.
And that's,
that's close enough for me.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so this is four times 10 to the one.
So that's just an example of how these kinds of things where you take things to
fractional powers,
either the square root,
which is to the one half or,
or the cube root to the one third.
All right,
uh,
the next problem,
let's see,
Neptune's moon Neary it has an orbital period of almost exactly one earth year.
If the massive net Pune is something or other,
what's it semi major access.
So you have p and m and you're asked for a,
uh,
that's a completely straightforward plug and chug problem because there's an
equation that relates to these three things.
And only tricky thing about this is,
uh,
that you have to make sure the units come out right?
All right?
The next one looks similar in form,
but it isn't considered a sunlight star orbited by planet planet with a period
of eight years.
So we have p the separation of the planet and the Star appears to be 20 arc
seconds.
So we have an angle that's alpha.
How far away is the star?
And you want to know d okay.
There is no equation that contains all,
all three of those things.
And so this is,
although it looks similar in form,
is actually a substantially more difficult problem,
uh,
going on problem for,
okay,
the important,
in fact,
there is such a star,
blah,
blah.
Does this fact make any difference in the foregoing calculation?
Explain.
The important thing to note about this is that I'm not asking you to do a
calculation.
This is not a calculation problem.
This is a comment you're supposed to say something about how the calculation
would go if you were to do it,
but you don't have to actually calculate anything there.
And then finally,
this last problem,
this is the sort of essay question here.
Uh,
the point here as I've,
as I've written down on the,
uh,
there's about Pluto,
the point here as I've written down on the actual paper itself,
there's no right answer to this.
Uh,
this is a thought question.
there are some people I know from the course evaluations who get disturbed by
this because they have the feeling that science ought to have right answers.
That is after all the point.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and I keep asking these sort of touchy feely humanities kinds of questions,
revel in it,
a go with it.
Uh,
and,
uh,
what we're looking for here is the same thing as your English teacher would be
looking for,
right.
Uh,
um,
although perhaps less emphasis on writing style,
but you know,
just,
uh,
have some thoughts,
do some reading,
understand something and say something intelligent and defendant.
Okay.
Uh,
and uh,
a paragraph or two,
you know,
two sentences,
probably too little.
A,
if it's more than two pages,
double spaced or one page,
single space,
I'm going to get really irritated because I have to read these things.
Uh,
and they're 80 of them.
and so,
uh,
don't go,
don't go nuts.
Uh,
again,
just be saying about it,
uh,
and say something and say something intelligent.
That's a,
that's all we ask.
Uh,
questions about the problem set or about procedural aspects of the course at
this stage?
Yeah.
If you do have some at some point,
uh,
send them,
send them to us on the classic server.
Yeah.
Oh,
go ahead.
What would you say is too short?
Oh,
the answer.
Well,
a sentence is too short.
Two sentences probably too short.
Unless they're pretty severe sentences.
Uh,
I mean it's got to be a paragraph,
you know,
otherwise you haven't really cleared your throat.
Uh,
but I don't want to say anything too precise about that.
If you've got a really keen sentence,
you know,
that might do the job.
Uh,
again,
sanded,
he ought to prevail.
Yes.
Uh,
we'll probably have one of that nature,
not necessarily of this kind about,
you know,
scientific controversies,
but about something.
Uh,
oh,
and I should say the way the tests will work out is it's going to be probably
slightly more than half calculation and slightly less than half.
There won't be essays because they're PR.
You've probably isn't time to do that on a 50 minute tests,
but there'll be less short answer questions and stuff like that.
Uh,
yeah.
Well,
we'll have these kinds of discussion things.
They won't be
the dominant part of the problems just as in this case,
it's six points out of this adds up to 20 points.
This one,
six other questions.
Okay.
As I say,
if you've got some,
let us know.
Okay.
So as I pointed out last time,
we're talking about exoplanets,
planets around other stars.
And the problem with the exoplanets is you can't see them direct like so you
can't
see the exoplanets
directly as blobs of light in the sky.
And so what do you do?
So I have to detect them,
obviously indirectly.
And here's a,
we'd got to invoke another one of Newton's laws.
So the key law here is now Newton's third law.
Newton's second law is f equals m.
A.
You may recall that explained to all the physics one 80,
uh,
Newton's third law is usually phrased in textbooks and stuff.
Has every action has an equal and opposite reaction?
Yeah,
I hate this formulation,
uh,
because it leads to really bad philosophy.
You know,
uh,
this is one of the whole problems with physics in general.
There are these words that seem to mean something,
uh,
words like force words like potential.
Uh,
and there these have technical meanings,
uh,
in physics that are actually different from the intuitive meaning that you have
in your head just from using them in everyday life.
And the big problem with introductory physics is getting people to use these
words as if they mean the physics definition rather than as if they mean the
everyday life,
uh,
definition.
And this leads,
as I say,
uh,
in extreme cases to all sorts of bad philosophy.
In fact,
the two most misused physics words that I know of are first of all,
relativity,
uh,
and everything is relative said Einstein.
Well,
no,
actually he said nothing of the kind.
Uh,
and the other one is uncertainty,
which has to do with quantum mechanics and you know,
uh,
and these are technical terms,
in physics.
And then they get sort of promoted to the state to,
uh,
use in philosophy as if they met what they mean in English.
So I don't like this because every action has an equal and opposite reaction.
Uh,
you can get into all sorts of bogus,
uh,
philosophy and I don't want to go there.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I would rather phrase this as conservation of momentum.
Uh,
and,
uh,
momentum,
as I say,
as a technical term,
it means,
uh,
m mass times velocity.
It's all it means.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
the kind of use that it's put in electoral politics or other things has nothing
to do with what's going on in physics.
Uh,
or I should say velocity,
uh,
one should be aware of is,
consists of two things.
It's not just the speed that something has,
but also its direction.
Uh,
and so direction council,
if you turn around and go at the same speed,
you've,
you've reversed your,
uh,
you now have negative velocity compared to where you start with,
this,
uh,
technically speaking makes this a vector quantity,
but again,
we won't go there.
Um,
okay,
so how does this work in the case of a planetary orbit?
So here's a planet.
It's on one side of it starts going this way,
uh,
and it's got some momentum and then half an orbit later,
it's over here going the other way.
Let's say it's orbiting some star in the middle and it's got more or less the
same speed,
but it's direction is reversed.
So over half an orbit,
uh,
so over one half orbit,
the momentum is reversed.
So it goes from being positive to negative or something like that.
Now Newton's third law says that momentum is conserved.
It has to total momentum of the system has to remain the same.
So something else has to change.
And here's the whole trek about finding exoplanets and that is that the star
moves too.
So,
uh,
when,
when the planets over here at this blue Arrow,
the star is here and it's also moving in the opposite direction,
uh,
and then half an orbit later,
the planet has come over to this side.
The star has moved or moved in the opposite direction.
It's now going this way.
Uh,
and uh,
so the star moves too.
That's key.
How much does the star move?
Well,
uh,
the two Momenta,
have to be equal and opposite.
This is what is equal and opposite about Newton's third law is that these things
have to cancel out.
So what you find is that the mass of the planet times the velocity of the planet
is equal to the mass of the star times the velocity of the star.
Uh,
and because the mass of the star is so much bigger,
so huge compared to the mass of the planet,
it's philocity much B must be much,
much smaller in order for these two things to be equal.
Uh,
okay.
what,
what are they orbiting around then?
If everything is,
is,
uh,
moving together,
their orbit,
they orbit around the center of mass,
so called
this is just,
you know,
where the balance point of a seesaw would kind of be a,
and so here we have,
uh,
here's the center of mass.
Here's,
uh,
here's the star moving this way,
way over here,
somewhere as a planet moving much faster.
Uh,
and let's define two quantities.
This is the distance from the planet to the center of mass.
Here's the distance of the star to the planet of Mass Stars Moving At v Starr
Planet is moving at v Planet.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you can define a total philocity,
which is equal to these two things added together.
And what does that mean?
That's the velocity where if you're on one of these objects,
the other appears to be moving relative to you.
So if I'm going this way and you're going that way,
we have a relative velocity equal to the sum of our individual velocities.
And there's also a total distance which can be defined,
which is by analogy,
the,
some of the distance from the planet to the center of mass and the start of the
center of mass.
And that's just the distance between these two objects.
The distance and the velocity in an elliptical orbit can change during the
course of the orbit.
Uh,
but for circular orbits or close to circular orbits,
they remain about the same or,
but you'll remember generally elliptical.
Uh,
and,
uh,
a way of saying this is that the maximum of the total different distance between
these two is this quantity.
A Sami major access.
Remember the semi major access is the long slice through the ellipse.
So when this is at a maximum,
that equals a,
the semi major access for our orbits that are nearly circular.
Uh,
you can sort of say in an offhand way,
well,
uh,
this,
Ditto doesn't change that much.
So it's the distance between the two objects.
All right?
Now as I mentioned,
uh,
VP m p is equal to v Star m star.
It is also true the way you figure out where the center of mass is.
DP A M P is equal to d star m star.
And the whole point of this is that this is a large quantity compared to the
mass of the planet.
And therefore these are small quantities compared to the,
to,
uh,
the distance.
The distance is in velocities,
uh,
taken by the planet
small.
But as it turns out,
a measurable in particular,
the Velocity,
uh,
is the thing,
the velocity of the star turns to be the thing that you can measure.
And so that's how you find,
uh,
determined that there's an exoplanet there.
What you do is you look for the reflex motion of the star planets going around
the stars.
Stars going around the center of mass also.
Uh,
and that is a motion that now these days can be observed.
And you can see why this might have happened only very recently because that
motion is really very small.
Let me give you some masses just to give you a sense of this.
We've already,
I've already written down that the sun's mass is about two times 10 to the 30
kilograms.
A just for reference,
the Earth's mass is six times 10 to the 24 kilograms.
So down by almost a factor of a Michigan,
uh,
and so,
the sun moves much slower than the earth does due to their mutual gravity.
Jupiter's the most massive of the planet.
Uh,
uh,
and it's at about two times 10 to the 27 kilograms,
so a thousand times smaller than the sun.
And so of course the sun moves a thousand times less because if Jupiter than it
does because of the earth.
Now of course,
the sun actually responds to all of these planets.
So it's actually executing some complicated motion,
which is the sub of the motions induced by all the planets.
But in fact,
uh,
Jupiter is,
is,
is significantly more massive than the rest of the planet.
So the,
by far the dominant motion that the sun goes through,
uh,
has to do with the orbit of Jupiter.
And so the consequence of this,
because the masters are so much smaller,
smaller,
is that the velocity of the star is much,
much less.
These two less than sign to me,
it's much,
much less than the velocity of the planet,
uh,
but it can nevertheless be detected.
Okay.
Now
what do we expect to see?
Supposing you can now go out and through means that we'll actually talk about it
on Thursday,
uh,
actually measure the velocities,
of starts in response to planet.
What do you expect,
uh,
to see,
in those,
uh,
in other stars?
And basically the answer to that is what you expect to see,
uh,
depends on what your expectations for solar systems are.
We've got one example,
or at least 10 years ago,
we had only one example.
And so,
uh,
you have to take what you know about our own solar system and infer what other
solar systems,
uh,
might want to look like.
And so at this point,
I want to show you some things about our own solar system.
Uh,
so a little slideshow of the solar system here.
All right.
Don't take notes.
Uh,
I'll tell you everything you need to know after we finished the pretty pictures.
Um,
okay.
So
starting from the inner,
inner most part of the solar system,
this is the innermost planet.
This is the planet.
Mercury looks much like the moon.
It's basically a rock,
uh,
with craters on it.
Uh,
there was a time when we thought that it's spin period was exactly the same as
it's orbital period.
So it keeps one face to the sun.
There's all kinds of science fiction based on that.
That turned out not to be true.
Uh,
but,
uh,
basically,
it's kind of a hot rock.
That's all you need to know about mercury.
Uh,
let's see.
Oh,
here's a closeup of a little piece of mercury surface and you would have a tough
time telling that this was a mercury rather than the moon or many other objects.
Uh,
rocky objects in the solar system.
Next one out is Venus.
Venus looks quite different because it's got a very thick atmosphere,
very thick carbon dioxide atmosphere.
This is all clouds that you're looking at here.
Uh,
and in fact,
the greenhouse effect,
which is supposed to be responsible perhaps for global warming,
was first studied and identified on Venus because it appears to have run a muck
on Venus.
The surface of Venus is extremely hot,
uh,
and it's covered with these really thick clouds.
So it was quite hard for a long time to get a handle on what was going on down
on the surface.
Uh,
this has now,
however,
been accomplished a,
they've put things into orbit that have radar and can,
uh,
view the topography.
Few that through the clouds,
they've also dropped things onto the surface of Venus.
The problem is at 700 degrees in it,
rain sulfur down there.
Uh,
so it's an unpleasant environment for machinery.
So things don't last very long,
but nevertheless,
uh,
they've gotten it some information.
Uh,
here's a little Venus landscape.
It's RF entirely,
artificially colored,
right?
Uh,
but the topography,
uh,
comes from these radar mapping missions.
Uh,
and,
uh,
here is a map of the whole of Venus,
made by these,
uh,
these orbiting missions.
Uh,
and so Venus is important,
uh,
primarily for,
for its atmosphere and as a kind of warning for what my,
uh,
potentially one day happen here.
If we're not careful,
a,
okay,
this is the third rock from the sun.
Uh,
99% of all Gail courses deal with what's going on on this little piece of cosmic
debris.
I'm not going to say any more about it,
therefore,
oh,
except for one thing,
it comes with this companion object.
This is the moon.
The moon is a very special thing because relative to its planet,
it's huge.
This really shouldn't be thought of as a planet and a moon,
but rather as a double planet,
uh,
here they are to scale.
Uh,
and that's much closer in s in size than any other moon planet system.
around the major planets,
uh,
moving outward.
Uh,
we come to Mars.
this is a,
uh,
this is about as good an image of Mars as you can get from the earth.
And you can see why people got excited about it.
These blace here,
turnout to change with time and in fact they change with the marsh and seasons.
So people got very excited.
I thought,
oh my goodness,
it's vegetation.
You know,
the seasons come,
go.
Uh,
and there's an polar ice cap up there obviously.
And,
uh,
a hundred years ago,
people,
uh,
somehow convinced themselves that there were canals and maybe cities and baby
people all over this planet.
Uh,
this turns out to be wrong.
It isn't vegetation.
It's actually dust storms that changes what you see.
And by now we have,
uh,
some,
much more close up views,
uh,
from things like the Viking missions and a number of more recent visions,
missions.
And this is basically a,
what the surface of Mars looks like.
It has this slight reddish tint overall,
uh,
and it's a bunch of rocks.
It has,
uh,
it has an atmosphere,
although it's less thick than the earth's atmosphere.
Uh,
now one of the interesting things about Mars is you can see features that look
like this.
Uh,
and uh,
this looks very much like river deltas.
You know,
you see these little tributaries coming into a big river.
This kind of looks like a,
uh,
Louisiana or something like that.
And so,
yeah,
people are pretty much convinced that there was once running water on Mars a,
and that's important because it is thought that the existence of life as we know
it,
uh,
is,
is dependent on the existence of liquid water.
Uh,
for a long time people thought that there was no liquid water.
Now on Mars,
it turns out that the particular temperature and atmospheric pressure that
exists on Mars,
uh,
means that water goes from the solid state,
from ice and Sublime's directly into the,
uh,
into the gaseous state.
Much like carbon dioxide does.
Here you have.
That's why it's called dry ice because carbon dioxide when you freeze it and Wa
and then more met up again,
turns directly into gas.
Water are supposed to do the same on Mars,
but there was just a month ago,
uh,
this interesting,
picture publish.
This is from an orbiting satellite orbiting Mars that's been taking a lot of
pictures.
This is pictures of two identical parts of the Martian surface,
one from 1999,
one from 2005.
And the claim is that there's new stuff down here and that the way and the
pattern of that new stuff and the way it must've come on.
Yes.
From stuff flowing down hill down the side of this crater.
Uh,
and so now people are thinking maybe there is something flowing around on Mars,
although clearly not a,
all that much of it.
But that would be exciting if it was confirmed.
Okay.
Out Beyond Mars is the asteroid belt filled with rocky chunks of stuff that
looked vaguely like this many,
many of them.
There are asteroids all over the solar system.
Uh,
most of them are between the orbits of Mars and Jupiter,
but there are other families that are elsewhere.
Some of these other families,
it has been suggested,
uh,
come from,
the asteroid belt,
but they've had collisions or other catastrophes and have been a bumped into
different orbits.
But most of the asteroids in between a Mars and Jupiter now out beyond,
uh,
the asteroid belt are a number of other planets and much of what we know about
these other planets come from a couple of satellites that look kind of like
this.
These are the voyager satellites that were launched in the 1970s and have been
traveling through the outer solar system ever since.
Uh,
this was a clever thing that they did a,
it turned out that,
uh,
in the seventies and eighties,
the outer planets,
Jupiter,
Saturn,
Uranus,
and Neptune were aligned in such a way that one satellite could catch them all
as they went past.
And each time it goes past one of these things that uses the gravitational
attraction of that planet to swing itself to the next one and then to the next
one.
And then to the next one.
And so,
uh,
these wonderful satellites for many years gave us a pictures of one planet after
another,
uh,
now,
which we now know quite a lot more about them.
We used to,
uh,
so here's Jupiter.
This is by far the most massive planet here.
You've got the famous red spot.
All that you see here is atmosphere and it's got very elaborate weather,
uh,
and the red spot and turns out to be a hurricane that has persisted for about
350 years.
Uh,
to us it seems like a,
an almost permanent feature,
although it's gotten fainter recently.
Um,
but it's sort of as if supposing you were a race of creatures,
uh,
who's a lifetime was about half a day and you were observing the earth and you
observe it for many lifetimes and you saw the same hurricane sitting down
somewhere in the Caribbean,
you would think that that little spot,
uh,
was kind of a permanent feature.
And that seems to be what this is.
It's a sort of really long lasting hurricane.
If you have a,
if you have you,
they have time lapse movies of this,
you can find them on the Internet where you can see that the,
the wind is actually circulating there.
Uh,
Jupiter has moons.
Many of them,
these before,
big ones you see here are the so called Galilean moons because they were
discovered by Galileo.
Uh,
they've also included a little one there,
many dozens of moons this size,
the moons.
Each of the moon's has its own peculiar characteristics.
I'm quite fond of this one.
This is the innermost moon,
it's called Io.
Uh,
sometimes referred to as the Pepperoni pizza moon.
and it's got the most elaborate volcanoes anywhere in the solar system.
It spews up sulfur,
uh,
all the time.
And then this software sort of melts and flows all over the surface and that's
what gives it its particular color.
Each of the other moons has interesting characteristics of its own.
Uh,
here's an interesting thing that the voyager satellites discovered.
uh,
they discovered that Jupiter has rings.
Uh,
it was not thought that Jupiter had rings from the Earth.
You can't see them.
Uh,
but from close up,
it became apparent that Jupiter has rings,
uh,
the same way Saturn does.
But of course,
the Saturn rings are the most spectacular.
Here's Saturn,
the next planet out.
You can see it too,
has whether banded things down here and then it has these very rings scene here
in various different from various different angles as Saturn goes through its
orbit.
Uh,
and these rings we now know are made up of a,
an individual little chunks of things.
Uh,
the voyager mission,
this is obviously artificially colored so that you can see all the different
rings and each one of those rings is made up of many,
many,
many little rocks.
Saturn to has moons.
This is tightened Saturn's big moon.
And you can see from here in this particular picture that Titan has an
atmosphere that makes it very interesting.
People have the feeling that,
uh,
places where there are atmospheres are potential sources of life.
And so people find tighten and interesting moon.
I actually liked this one better.
Uh,
this is me.
Muss.
It's adjust a rocky moon,
but you can see it's kind of cut.
The great grandmother of all creditors up there.
Uh,
this thing got slammed into by some asteroid that was just barely not big enough
to blow the whole thing apart.
Uh,
and but it raised this big pucker on the side of the moon,
uh,
moving out to the next planet,
which is Uranus in ordinary light.
You can't actually see any features.
Again,
you're looking at the atmosphere.
There are clouds.
Uh,
but this picture was taken in a particular kind of red light,
which brings out the cloud features.
And uh,
what you can see is that it's got a bandage structure the same as Jupiter and
Saturn,
but interestingly,
the bands are on its side.
One of the peculiar features of Jupiter of your anus is that it is,
is that,
uh,
rotate sideways rather than kind of up and down a uniquely among the planet.
This planet to has rings.
It also has moons.
Here's another favorite moon of mine.
Uh,
this is Miranda.
And this looks like what happened was that it actually did get blown apart by
some impact,
but then fell back together again and you can see that it looks like it's been
chopped into pieces and then sort of thrown back into,
uh,
together again moving out to the next planet.
Here's Neptune.
Neptune again has weather.
Uh,
here's the big dark spot on a Neptune.
Similar to the big red spot on,
uh,
on Jupiter.
This little cloud here is called scooter because it moves faster than the,
uh,
than the rest of the weather on Neptune.
It's actually kind of a mystery.
How come Neptune has all this weather?
Because it's very cold out there.
There isn't a whole lot of energy that should be in the atmosphere and nobody
can quite figure out how this is supposed to work.
Neptune has moons.
Here's,
here's Neptune's biggest moon.
This is Triton.
You can see this sort of frontier here between two types of typography sort of
moves around.
Uh,
and that is thought to be due to a weather,
a various kinds,
methane,
snow,
stuff like that.
Uh,
and then by now this was the last planet,
a voyager two,
uh,
examined and then it went past them and it took,
this took a lovely shot.
Uh,
looking back at the solar system here is Neptune and Triton.
as,
uh,
the voyager mission moved out,
into the,
uh,
outer solar system beyond the large planets.
Now,
Pluto wasn't aligned properly to take part in this.
This is,
these are pictures of Pluto.
This is a picture of Pluto from the ground.
Here it is from the space telescope.
You guys,
you can see it's got a moon.
This is kind of all we know about Pluto at the moment.
There is a spacecraft that is currently on route to Pluto.
Uh,
and uh,
when it arrives there a couple of decades from now,
decades from now,
I guess,
uh,
we'll know much war.
Now you may be aware that there was a little bit of fuss about Pluto over the
summer.
Let me show you why.
Here it is.
This is what all the fuss is about.
This is a three pictures sort of shown as a movie.
See this thing over here?
That's moving,
that's moving because unlike all the other objects in this picture,
uh,
that thing is not a distant star.
That is a planet in the outer solar system.
This is the one that for a while was called Xena.
Now it's called Eris.
Uh,
and this is,
these are the discovery photographs of this.
Uh,
then,
uh,
as,
as they kept taking pictures,
they could plot the orbit.
Uh,
they determined the orbit of the thing using an equation you've already
discovered.
They figure out how far away it is,
uh,
from how far away it is and how bright it is.
You can figure out how big it is.
And the problem that era's present is it's bigger than Pluto.
Uh,
and,
uh,
said there are a whole bunch of other things out there that have also been
discovered.
Uh,
also,
uh,
as big or bigger than Pluto.
Here are the eight,
currently largest known,
so called Trans Neptunian objects,
sometimes also called [inaudible] belt objects.
Uh,
here's Eris,
here's Pluto here.
A bunch of other ones.
They find these things like one or two of them a year now.
And so we can confidently expect that 20 years from now they're going to be a
hundred such things.
So you have the problem.
Oh,
you should.
It's worth noting these things also have moons and some of them have a moon,
uh,
to,
to planet ratio similar to the Earth and the moon.
But here's the earth for scale.
All of them,
including Pluto and Eris,
very much smaller than the earth.
And so you've got yourself a problem.
If you're going to count Pluto,
how do you not count these other things?
And so the first suggestion was why you ought to count Pluto.
And you oughta count a bunch of these other things too.
And so there was going to be,
you know,
12 planets or something like that,
and,
and presumably many more to come.
And then people decided,
you know,
the heck with this whole bunch of things,
uh,
we'll give him a different name.
We won't call them planets at all.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that was what was finally determined leading to all sorts of,
you know,
safe Pluto campaigns from disgruntled third graders.
Uh,
who,
uh,
yes.
Thank you very much.
Uh,
who,
uh,
were unhappy about having to re memorize all the mnemonics that,
tell you the planets and the solar says actually if you include it,
things like cow are,
you're like,
go get yourself into trouble trying to learn them all.
Uh,
and uh,
they're lots and lots of these things.
Okay.
So,
uh,
just a little about the geography of the solar system.
Here's the inner solar system out to the orbit of Jupiter with the asteroids and
stuff.
Here's the outer solar system starting with Jupiter.
Here's Pluto.
Uh,
and you'll notice that Pluto really is an elliptical orbit,
much more elliptical than the other planets.
It also turns out it's the orbit is tipped all the other planets,
the orbits are in the same plane as each other.
Pluto's orbit is tipped out of the plane.
Uh,
here's one of the,
these other Trans Neptunian objects.
Here's its orbit and you can see that it goes way,
way out in,
is highly elliptical,
very much out of the plane.
This is in general,
true of these,
uh,
what are now called Dwarf Planet or Trans Neptunian objects or corporate belt
objects.
Uh,
but it's also true that there's a further component of the solar system.
Even beyond that.
Here's sadness orbit that again is Sedna,
this orbit.
So we've now gone up a degree in scale,
and then there's this whole cloud of stuff out there called the Oort cloud.
Uh,
and this is,
uh,
this is where the comments live.
Comments are sort of ice balls.
Uh,
we can't see them individually out in New York cloud,
but sometimes they collide with each other and one of them falls into the inner
solar system and answer does it heats up?
It's made out of ice.
The ice melt gets streams backward,
and we get these very spectacular things,
uh,
comments cause all kinds of mayhem.
They killed dinosaurs,
for example.
Uh,
and,
uh,
recently we've seen an example of this.
This is a comic called Shoemaker Levy that's broken up into a bunch of pieces.
And in 1994,
those pieces slammed into Jupiter.
Uh,
and here you see the various,
the effect of the various pieces of this comment that,
that hit Jupiter.
And so a comments can be dangerous things when they land on your planet.
Okay.
Uh,
this is the outer solar system.
Again.
Here's the tip orbit of Pluto.
That's the orbit of Neptune.
Here's voyager one.
Voyager two,
traveling now outward.
They are escaping from the solar system,
uh,
and the very edges of the sun's influence where you might say,
the,
uh,
the sun,
the solar system ends and the interstellar medium begins,
uh,
are indicated here.
Each of these things means a slightly different,
uh,
boundary to the sun's influence.
Uh,
but the voyagers are going to get there sometime in our lifetime.
So they will be the first manmade things that actually pass out of our solar
system.
Uh,
and that's as far as this goes.
let me turn the lights back on here.
Um,
okay,
so much for the solar system.
Now here's the important question.
I just threw a whole bunch of facts at you.
Fact Information.
Pretty pictures.
We have a lot of facts and information and pretty pictures.
The voyagers took many thousands of pictures and uh,
other,
uh,
and other acquired other forms of information as well.
They've been many other
spacecraft flying around our solar system for quite some time.
We know a lot of things.
Here's the question.
Now that you know all this stuff,
what do you do with that information?
So what,
uh,
do you do with all this solar system and fall?
One thing you could do is write it all down and memorize it.
Uh,
I strongly advise against that.
you know,
this is what the Internet is for.
There are a whole bunch of websites out there that'll tell you everything you
could possibly want to know about all of the objects and all of the planets,
moons,
everything else.
Uh,
so that isn't actually a productive way.
I don't think of spending your time.
So what would you rather do?
What would one,
what would be a more productive way of thinking about this material?
Uh,
and now I want to step back and remind you of how science works.
Remember the scientific method,
they probably taught you something about this when you were like 11 or 12 years
old,
and you'll remember how this works.
Uh,
so scientific method,
uh,
so you have a hypothesis,
which is a fancy word for a gas.
Uh,
maybe you have competing hypotheses and on the basis of this hypothesis you
form,
we formulate some kind of experiment.
A good experiments are sometimes called controlled experiments.
And on the basis of the results of the experiment,
you determine how much you believe the hypothesis or which hypothesis you
believe.
And then,
you know,
you may modify your hypothesis or change it altogether.
And the men do more experiments.
And by iterating this procedure,
uh,
you develop an understanding of whatever it is you're trying to think about.
Uh,
okay.
No,
not really.
Certainly not in astronomy.
Astronomy doesn't work this way at all.
Think about what an experiment would be in astronomy.
Okay.
So here's a ball of gas.
The size of the sun made out of pure hydrogen.
Here's another ball of gas.
The size of the sun made out of pure helium.
We stick them in the sky and watch them evolve for 10 billion years.
Okay?
No,
you can't do experiments in astronomy.
It doesn't work that way at all.
So there has to be some other way of approaching it.
And the reason for this is the distronic me is not an experimental science.
It's an observational science.
This is true of many other scientists,
a lot of scientists,
a lot of biology,
particularly environmental or ecological aspects of biology work this way.
All of the social sciences,
uh,
you can't do controlled experiments in child development.
Uh,
that's just ugly.
and uh,
so these are observational,
uh,
sciences and this has a different methodology.
Uh,
and it starts as its name would suggest with observations and uh,
you go out and you find a bunch of things,
uh,
whether they're butterflies or planets or whatever they are.
Uh,
and what do you do when you found a whole bunch of things?
What's the next step?
The next step is classification.
You put them into categories and uh,
it's important to get this right.
If you're dealing with,
for example,
animals and you classify them as things that live in the ocean and things that
live in live on land,
then you're going to have fish and whales in the same category,
and you're going to have lizards and frogs and snakes in the same category with,
uh,
with people and bears and things like that.
And this isn't going to lead you to,
to,
uh,
a deep understanding because you haven't got the categories right.
And so the classification is very important.
And what it leads to when you get it right is a useful interpretation of what,
uh,
what is going on.
Uh,
this is interpretation and it's just a fancy word for a good story.
A,
these are the kinds of things we write down in textbooks.
Uh,
the,
uh,
astronomer sometimes dignify this with the fancy word scenario,
but it's basically a story.
Uh,
and on the basis of this story,
you say,
well,
we'd better check out,
see whether this story holds up.
Uh,
let's do more observations.
and,
uh,
the,
all of these connections work in all directions.
And so this is actually a,
a better description of how an observational science has done,
uh,
then this kind of thing,
up here.
So,
uh,
now having gone through that little piece of philosophy,
let's apply it in practice.
I've just described to you some observations,
some observations of the solar system.
Now what I'm going to do is I'm going to take those objects that I just showed
you and classified or attempt to.
So,
uh,
let us,
classify,
these are now going to be categories of solar system objects.
Yeah.
So I claim,
uh,
or at least it's the start of a good story that there are six categories of
objects in the solar system.
The first is the sun,
uh,
which I didn't actually show you,
which is 99% of all of the mass in the solar system and,
uh,
almost all of the energy and a and heat and so forth.
Then there are the inner planets,
uh,
sometimes called the terrestrial planets because the earth is the a prime
example.
Okay.
And these are rocks.
Basically that would be silicon iron,
uh,
elements like that with a very thin
surface coating of ice,
thin coating of ice,
of ice,
uh,
in some cases melted in some cases.
Gaseous.
What I mean by ice is not necessarily water ice,
uh,
but also things like ammonia and methane and other compounds have that kind.
Uh,
this coding is very thin.
If you had a scale model of the earth that was six feet across,
you put your hand up against it.
You wouldn't even feel that it was wet from the oceans.
So not very much.
Uh,
and these have masses,
these things,
these inner planets of,
I dunno,
10 to the minus seven to 10,
to the minus five of the sun.
Yeah.
Uh,
and they're in basically circular orbits.
Then you've got the asteroids,
which are,
uh,
irregular,
very small rocks,
uh,
in,
mostly in orbit between,
uh,
between Mars and Jupiter and out beyond the asteroids.
Uh,
you've got the outer planets sometimes called the Jovian planets.
because Jupiter is the prime example of these things.
And these are quite different from the inner planet.
Uh,
they've got a lot of gas on ice.
uh,
both gas,
which I'm defining here to be hydrogen and helium and ice,
which I'm defining to be,
as I said,
water,
ammonia,
methane,
yeah.
And similar compounds.
Uh,
and these are more massive,
uh,
10 to the minus four to 10 to the minus three of the sun.
Uh,
they have rings many moons.
Yeah.
Also circular orbits
and all of these orbits,
both,
both these planets in these planets are basically in one plane out beyond
the Jovian planets are these Trans Neptunian objects are quite poor belt
objects,
quite per belt objects.
This is Pluto,
et cetera.
We don't really know what they are yet,
but it seems like they're probably going to be rocky just to judge from their
size and,
and,
and mass.
Uh,
so we think they're rocky there.
A low mass,
less than 10 to the minus seven of the mass of the sun.
And they are in elliptical,
you elliptical and inclined orbits
way out there.
And then finally in the outer region in this so called Oort cloud,
you have the comments,
which are a little snow balls,
balls of ice.
Again,
ice in this generic sense.
So there's the six categories that I would claim exist in the solar system.
And here's my problem with the whole Pluto debate.
The Pluto debate was basically about whether these guys are going to count as
planets,
but the thing is planets is already a bad description because it contains two
quite different categories,
namely these inner terrestrial planets and the Outer Jovian planets.
And so it seems to me that arguing whether category five should be part of some
category that already contains two fundamentally different kinds of objects,
uh,
is kind of a strange argument to be having.
Uh,
either we should split these two things off from each other or if we're going to
join these two kinds of categories,
fine.
Bring in anything you like.
I don't care at the asteroids to,
and in fact,
in the original proposal,
one of the asteroids qualified as well.
Uh,
and so it doesn't seem to me,
uh,
that this,
controversy was really paying justice to an appropriate classification of the
things in the solar system.
Okay.
So now having classified it,
the next step is interpretation.
Uh,
and I think I will leave that.
Let's see how we doing for time.
Yes.
I'll leave that one for next time.
So the question is going to be,
now that you have these six kinds of objects,
what is the story you tell about how the solar system evolved and what the
intern does that tell you about what other kinds of planets you should see
around other stars?